okay hi I'm Manny Jimenez I'm director
for human development in the world back
east asia region and I cover issues to
have to sit with education alpha social
and I want to address actually a
question that none though some problem
based on how we may increase access to
education in developing countries and
you come from Indonesia just say two
things one is the lations done a
lot to be increased education access
past 30 years a lot more kids in
Indonesia are not graduating from of
fine-grained seconders the big issue is
are they ensure that the poor families
individuals poor students Asia stay in
school don't drop button good and get
great on education and here programs
such as the boss program and nature that
school grants to 23 education schools
it's one of those two so he will help
different quality of education in
Tunisians another is to make sure that
for these poor families that they might
have access to scholarships to ensure
that Jewish kids back stay in school and
are able to come in the cost but there's
just an example and wish you